[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur TV 78 pour le 7 8
c'est votre émission pour bien démarrer
la soirée dans les Yvelines avec au
programme de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ceci février une semaine
décisive pour le gouvernement sur la
réforme des retraites le projet de loi
est examiné depuis cet après-midi par
les députés à l'Assemblée nationale et
demain une troisième journée de
mobilisation contre le texte se
déroulera à l'appel d'une inter
syndicale quelle perturbations sont à
prévoir on fait le point dans cette
édition la député renaissance des
Yvelines Natalia pouzirate sera
d'ailleurs avec nous pour parler de ce
sujet mais aussi d'un autre elle
organise ce jeudi une conférence débat
sur la fin de vie ce sera
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en présence d'une
ministre d'élus mais aussi
d'intervenants et du monde médical et
associatif la convention citoyenne sur
le sujet doit rendre ses conclusions en
mars
et puis le Football Club de Versailles
n'est plus leader du championnat de
National et ce après la première défaite
en 2023 sa première défaite en 2023
trois buts contre Bourg Péronnas
vendredi les Yvelines noires restent
néanmoins au contact de la première
place à deux points seulement de
Martigues nous reviendrons sur ce match
et nous parlerons de la saison en cours
réussie pour le moment avec le défenseur
du FC Versailles Thibault Jacques qui
sera notre invité d'autres résultats
sport aussi à venir avec vous Nicolas
dandry bonsoir bonsoir vous remplacez
une deuxième fois Mickael el midoro qui
décidément est aux abonnés absents sur
la chronique sport de ce lundi on va
parler de quoi dans les résultats sport
aujourd'hui c'était pas aux abonnés
absents les Trappistes ce week-end parce
que bah ils ont gagné face à
Garenne-Colombes 1 à 0 une victoire dans
la douleur quand même on parle de
football c'est du football exactement de
la Régionale 2 et puis je vous parlerai
aussi de rugby le rugby vlades se
portent plutôt bien ou encore de basket
et là attrape ça va pas très bien on
verra tout à l'heure le score face à
Orléans assez lourd légalement des
invités sur cette partie sport oui
effectivement nous recevons le président
qui va le président pardon Jean-Pierre
Rouyer de l' USM Viroflay qui va nous
parler de du cross de la sablière et
puis Alan Brachet vainqueur 2022 du
cross de la sablière alors Jean-Pierre
Royer en quoi consiste ce cross
c'est un cross country classique qui
existe depuis 1977 à Viroflay on fête
cette année la 41e édition donc c'est
ouvert à tous aux enfants à partir de 7
ans jusqu'aux adultes il y a 7 6 ou 7
course donc de course adulte un Costco
un cross long et donc on a qu'à aussi
les sportifs de handicap avec six géolé
de cette année et
donc effectivement
tout ça dans la bonne humeur et on
espère le beau temps dimanche dans un
instant tout est prêt à la neuve pour
cette 41e édition oui tout est prêt du
coup tout le monde est au kiwi sur qui
vivent pour pour que tout se passe bien
et on espère du coup le beau temps comme
dit Jean-Pierre et en plus donc
elle est bien placée dans la saison
entre les régionaux de cross et les
livres de cross donc j'espère que tout
le monde sera présent on en dit un peu
plus dans un instant à suivre aussi les
informations du jour on fera le point
aussi sur les perturbations prévues pour
la journée de demain un jour de
mobilisation nationale contre la réforme
des retraites ce sera avec vous tout à
l'heure Céline Charles bonsoir avec des
perturbations ça on s'attend encore une
journée difficile demain encore une
journée de mobilisation massive qui va
porter son lot de perturbations
notamment plutôt dans les secteurs du
transport et de l'éducation on fera le
point en fin d'émission vous connaissez
le programme avant de commencer petit
coup d'œil à la météo de demain
retour du froid dans les Yvelines il
faudra vous couvrir et aussi peut-être
gratter votre pare-brise demain matin
mais le soleil sera de la partie il fera
0° à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Houdan et même -1 degré à Rambouillet
dans le sud du département dans
l'après-midi toujours le soleil et le
froid c'est toujours un poil plus frais
à Rambouillet avec 4 degrés 5 degrés sur
le reste du territoire et ce mardi 7
février nous fêterons les Eugénie
et comme à chaque édition du 7 8 le
point sur les informations du jour ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité
yvelinoise de ce lundi à 6 février c'est
avec Gabriel Gontier
le quartier de la clef Saint-Pierre
réaménagé et végétalisé à l'horizon des
JO de Paris 2024 vendredi 3 février
Jean-Michel fourgousse mer d'Élancourt a
signé un contrat d'aménagement régional
ces deux données un grand souffle aussi
ascartier
dans la rénovation dans la modernisation
de la meilleure
adaptation aux questions que nous pose
nos administrés donc c'est un grand
projet alors bien entendu tout cela
s'est extrêmement poussé aussi avec
l'arrivée des JO parmi les
transformations prévues pour 2023 les
réaménagements paysagers du premier
rond-point avenue Maurice Dassault sur
le thème des jeux ou encore celui de la
place de Berlin et le fleurissement du
second rond-point le couteau tel est
estimé à 4 millions d'euros hors-taxe
dont un million financé par la Région si
la région ne venait pas accompagner
toutes les communes de d'Île-de-France
et bien beaucoup seraient amené à ne
plus investir à moins investir une
commune qui n'investit plus une commune
qui n'est plus attractive et puis je
rappelle également que nous sommes dans
un pays où 70% d'investissement public
c'est les collectivités locales le jour
où les collectivités locales
n'investissent plus c'est l'économie qui
est en panne la Croix-Rouge se modernise
et regroupe ses activités samedi 4
février avaient lieu l'inauguration des
nouveaux locaux de l'association à
Guyancourt en présence du président
national le but regrouper toutes les
activités sur un même site après les
journées de grève des 19 et 31 janvier
la mobilisation continue contre le
projet de réforme des retraites vendredi
3 février avait lieu une manifestation
au flambeau à Mantes-la-Jolie Poissy
Versailles et Rambouillet organisé par
la CGT et l’inter syndicale
départementale des Yvelines les
syndicats appellent à une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation le mardi 7
février
55% c'est le taux de participation aux
élections municipales à Buchelay ce
dimanche Stéphane Tremblay qui assurait
l'intérim depuis décembre dernier après
la démission de Paul Martinez a été élue
la liste du candidat sans étiquette à
récolter plus de 60 % des voix ils
devancent largement ses adversaires fade
gazouani et Saphia el manani et on
termine avec notre image du jour
l'Europe était à l'honneur ce matin au
lycée Jean d'Albert de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye l'euro député
Marie-Pierre vedren est venue à la
rencontre des lycéens au programme de la
matinée des discussions sur différents
thèmes européens
et si vous aussi près de chez vous vous
êtes témoin d'une information d'un fait
qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à le
dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news alors vous
l'avez entendu l'une des informations à
retenir on est à la veille de cette
nouvelle journée de mobilisation à
contre la réforme des retraites on va
reparler de ce sujet dans un instant
avec les prévisions en termes de
perturbations et Natalia pouzirev sera
notre invité à partir de 18h30 elle est
actuellement dans l'hémicycle puisque le
projet de loi est examiné depuis
aujourd'hui par les députés à
l'Assemblée nationale avant cela donc on
ouvre tout de suite dans le 7 8 une page
sport
[Musique]
et on va parler de course à pied on le
disait avec nos invités avec Nicolas
Landry qui est toujours avec moi en
plateau ce dimanche c'est le 41e cross
de la sablière c'est à partir de 9h30 du
côté de la commune de Viroflay au
programme des courses pour les enfants à
6 km à 11 km et il y a une course pour
les enfants et également à 6 km et 11 km
voilà donc trois courses au programme et
pour nous en parler je le disais on le
disais tout à l'heure il y a deux
invités avec nous en plateau Jean-Pierre
Rouyer qui est le président de l'USM
Viroflay qui a organisé bien sûr ce
cross de la sabière et également Alan
brachelet brachelet pardon un triathlète
de 25 ans on le disait tout à l'heure
tout est prêt à quelques jours de
l'événement là on est dans les starting
blocks il y a 4 course enfant et pas une
mais une course crosse-cour une course
cross long en supplément forcément
pour les adultes donc à partir de 9h30
pour les plus petits dimanche matin et
ben je trouve toute la matinée donc
aujourd'hui et ce soir on est à 700
inscrits déjà inscrits en ligne on peut
encore jusqu'à jeudi soir en ligne et
après vendredi samedi éventuellement
dimanche au siège du club ou sur place
directement dimanche matin un quart
d'heure avant le début de la course
sachant qu'il vaut mieux s'y prendre un
peu à l'avance parce que il y aura je
pense beaucoup de monde on essaye cette
année de battre les 1100 participants on
était à 1086 l'année dernière on
essaiera de battre ce record cette année
sachant que je pense qu'il va faire beau
froid mais très beau et le parcours
n'est pas trop trop au bois donc je
pense que tout est tout est en place
pour que ça fasse une bonne une bonne
course dimanche et de bonnes
performances pour tout le monde tous les
voyants sont ovaires Nicolas alors
justement vous parlez il va peut-être on
annonce des températures assez froides
comment on se prépare face à la
fraîcheur Alan sachant que voilà c'est
on est toujours en hiver et forcément il
faut habituer le corps à cette
température du coup pour se préparer ce
qu'il faut c'est un bon échauffement
donc peut-être que l'échauffement il y
aura plus longtemps que si il fait chaud
donc réussir à chauffer peut-être pour
ceux qui ont fait un crosse court et le
cross long 30 minutes au moins minimum
avant la course et si le corps est chaud
dès le départ il sera habitué et du coup
il y aura pas il y aura pas de problème
pendant la course nous disait tout à
l'heure Alan dans le calendrier il est
très bien placé cet événement tout à
fait là le week-end dernier c'était les
régions de cross donc le weekend
prochain il y a pas de compétition au
calendrier pas de cross
au niveau de la fédération en tout cas
et les LIFA donc les intérêts régionaux
la semaine d'après donc dans deux
semaines alors vous dites que le
parcours va pas être trop boueux
justement quel est-il ce parcours est-ce
que il y a il y a de l'altitude est-ce
que il y a une il y a une c'est un
parcours compliqué ou pas oui parce que
d'abord il entièrement boisé dans la
forêt de Meudon donc c'est aussi c'est
quand même assez rare et puis il est
aussi occidenté parce que quand on
devient reflets vers illicite tous ceux
qui connaissent un petit peu de côté de
poche fontaine c'est quand même assez
assez pointu et il y a quand même c'est
de sacré moment
comment a passé et
donc le cross le parcours je pense est
assez est assez varié et très
intéressant 41 éditions comment on
arrive à se renouveler chaque année bah
c'est difficile pour un tas de raisons y
compris sur le plan du budget parce
qu'effectivement c'est plus en plus
coûteux et de plus en plus difficile
donc c'est un tel événement il faut
beaucoup d' accord
ou la police la commune principaux il
faut aussi beaucoup de communication
pour effectivement pour attirer du monde
ça se fait pas comme ça donc c'est ben
c'est un travail de très longue haleine
très difficile et surtout le même jour
même il faut quand même au moins 60
bénévoles pour assurer la l'événement en
plus des partenaires privés qui nous
aident sur la sécurité sur la santé sur
le chronomètre et également le les
services municipaux qui travaillent déjà
dans la semaine pour installer tout ce
qui va avec les barnums les tables et
chaises et puis forcément le parcours le
jour même c'est une grosse machinerie
derrière tout ça est-ce qu'on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui après 41 éditions ce sera
la 41e ce week-end c'est l'un des plus
gros événements la matière en
Île-de-France dans le département des
Yvelines oui je pense que oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a d'abord il y a
moins de crosses qui sont organisés
d'abord en France en Île-de-France qu'on
te dit des difficultés que je viens
d'évoquer d'une part et puis d'autre
part ben comment c'est de plus en plus
compliqué parce que je pense que c'est
pas une machine qui se met en place
automatiquement année apre année c'est
chaque année on met carrément les
compteurs à zéro pour pour retrouver
tout ce qu'il faut des partenaires
un nouveau parcours
et et tout relancer toutes les machines
par rapport à la communication quel est
votre
objectif cette année vous allez gagner
l'année dernière en 2022 déjà avec quel
chrono et puis peut-être nous annoncer
le chrono que vous visez cette année si
vous voulez pas dévoiler trop
d'informations
voilà on accepte mais voilà alors
Jean-Pierre est un peu emballé j'ai fini
trois gemmes l'année dernière
l'objectif de cette année c'est de faire
un meilleur chrono de 1 de 2 d'avoir des
meilleurs sensations et de trois mon
objectif sera au LIFA parce que du coup
j'ai fait les régions de cross et je
suis qualifié au olifa donc l'objectif
ce sera plutôt olifa pour réussir à
décrocher une qualification pour les
championnats de France et pour se
préparer pour être mieux on imagine
c'est un entraînement toute l'année pour
performer sur ce genre de d'événements
c'est un entraînement alors oui c'est un
événement à l'année après ma préparation
elle se fait aussi pour l'été pour la
piste et je suis encore de 1500 et 800
depuis l'année dernière et je me suis
mis surtout à l'athlétisme depuis que je
travaille à Viroflay et donc la
[Musique]
vis-à-vis des plus jeunes premièrement
deuxièmement c'est un événement familial
il y a beaucoup de familles qui vont
participer ensemble il y a une famille
dans la famille dugion qui sont je crois
à cinq ou si inscrits il y a tous les
cousins les parents peut-être même les
grands-parents bon moi je l'ai fait en
1978 mon fils l'a fait plus tard et
j'espère que ma petite fille le fera
bientôt donc sur Viroflay c'est un
événement parce que culturel tout le
monde connaît le cross et depuis
longtemps et ça fait partie au-delà de
la compétition humaine c'est un
événement familial sur un dimanche
d'hiver ou en fin de compte ce sera la
fête du sport à Viroflay on jouait
l'événement familier aussi à la
solidarité parce que pour la bonne cause
il y aura une collecte de bouchons
également qui sera effectué parce
qu'effectivement on accepte les sportifs
sont de handicap on les accueille
volontiers et cette année on boit aussi
un autre record il y aura six géolettes
de trois clubs différents des d'une de
l'espoir des bouchons de l'espoir et de
fraternités qui est une un club de Paris
qui est effectivement aura aussi une
geolète et donc effectivement tout le
monde partira en même temps et tout le
monde participait au cross dimanche sera
la fête personne ne sera écartée très
rapidement 1100 en participant la
prochaine vous l'avez dit au tout début
l'objectif c'est de faire plus c'est que
c'est faisable vous pensez faisable
c'est pas un objectif a priori comment
une obsession mais bon c'est pour pas
effectivement pour pour garder le pour
garder le le bon cap quoi c'est un peu
sale de l'idée bon après effectivement
on pourra prendre accueillir un peu plus
mais après au bout d'un moment il y a
aussi des obligations différentes il
peut y avoir des dangers notamment des
bousculades de départ des choses comme
ça donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a un
script aujourd'hui on organise plus de
course enfant pour éviter ce genre de
problème bien sûr toutes les
informations sur le site du cross de la
sablière à retrouver un sur donc voilà
vous voyez il s'affiche en bas de
l'écran vous allez le faire Nicolas vous
êtes prêt non je serai pas prêt non ça
va être un peu compliqué en tout cas on
retrouve toutes les informations merci à
vous deux d'être passé en plateau pour
en parler je rappelle un 41e édition de
ce cross de la sablière ce dimanche à
9h30 c'est à Viroflay on va ouvrir la
page des résultats sport à présent
Nicolas et peut-être juste avant un
petit mot sur un autre événement on
reste aussi dans la dépense physique
peut-être que vous y serez à celui
exactement oui parce que alors on a le
choix soit courir soit faire du vélo ou
les deux parce que vous connaissez les
principes du Bike & Run c'est la dixième
édition de cette compétition du côté de
Guyancourt un événement organisé par le
triathon triathlon club Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines ce sera aux étangs de la
minière une course de 15 km pour les
adultes à partir de 16 ans rendez-vous à
partir de 10h au Centre sportif des
Trois Mousquetaires les inscriptions et
les informations sur le site
www.triathlon-scaille.fr bon l'animation
ne s'est pas affiché peut-être qu'on
pourra leur proposer à nos
téléspectateurs dans un instant puisque
j'ai contre annoncé je m'excuse auprès
de la Régie effectivement la page des
résultats sport duquel c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'ils ont été un peu perdus et
on ouvre tout de suite cette page sport
Nicolas avec des résultats rugby
puisqu'on jouait sur les terrains de
rugby ce week-end effectivement dans le
championnat de régional une ce weekend
de match à l'extérieur pour des équipes
Yvelines l'Union rugby centre 78 s'est
imposé sur le terrain de Créteil Choisy
une victoire 33 à 22 du côté de
Tremblay-en-France
c'est incliné face au club de terre de
France 21 17 au classement l'URSS se
place en deuxième position dans la poule
une et Chevreuse conserve sa première
place dans la poule 2 direction les
parquets de basket après l'été en rugby
les parquet de basket exactement Grégory
les clubs de centre Val de Loire
nord-issent pas au trappiste après leur
défaite la semaine dernière à domicile
face à Chartres trap 5 lignes sur le
parquet d'Orléans sur un score assez
large 90 62 28 points d'écart au
classement les 5 continents à Pointe à
la sixième place les Trappistes pourront
se relancer à domicile ce samedi 11
février face à Bayeux les meilleurs
nouvelles on l'espère en handball et
effectivement Grégory une bonne nouvelle
du côté de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
puisque les féminines ont dominé leur
adversaire d'Ivry 29 21 une victoire
face au deuxième au 12e pardon et
dernier du classement les inintènes se
classent à la quatrième place à égalité
de pont avec Rosières Saint-Julien la
prochaine rencontre est un adversaire
direct pour Montigny-le-Bretonneux elles
iront jouer le samedi 11 février à 3
donc je vais aussi dans les catégories
masculines oui la deuxième journée en
demi-tente pour le handball masculin en
National 3 d'abord une contreperformance
à domicile de Houilles Le Vésinet
carrière 24 à 26 passe à Saint-Mandé de
leur côté les plaisirs sont allés
s'imposer en Bretagne du côté de Morlaix
plougoven plus gonven pardon le score 29
27 les deux clubs sont situés
respectivement à la 6e et à 8e place au
classement on ouvre à présent une page
football dans un instant à suivre notre
invité du FC Versailles mais tout
d'abord on parle de trap oui
l'invincibilité en 2023 se poursuit pour
l'Étoile Sportive de Trappes les
Yvelinois se sont imposés un but à zéro
contre La Garenne-Colombes une victoire
dans la douleur grâce à une solide
défense les Trappistes peuvent
poursuivre leur dynamique positive
regardez
les Trappistes reçues trois sur trois en
2023 l'Étoile Sportive de Trappes
enchaîne avec une troisième victoire
consécutive le résultat 1 à 0 une
rencontre difficile face aux valeurs aux
joueurs de Garen Colomb les voisins des
Hauts-de-Seine n'ont rien lâché jusqu'à
la fin de la rencontre ça a été un match
très difficile très serré au final les
deux équipes ont beaucoup beaucoup
défendus ont réussi à trouver la faille
sur
sur une action collective très bonne
action collective et bon on a réussi à
marquer ce but là qui a été important
parce que je pense que la première
équipe qui marquait sur ce match là a
gagné le match avec un score vierge à la
mi-temps la situation s'est débloqué en
seconde période contre le cours du jeu
Garen Colomb se procure plusieurs
occasions dont cette action face au but
juste après grâce à un enchaînement
collectif trap ouvre le score 1 à 0
on voulait les attendre un petit peu bas
on a été surpris par la hauteur du bloc
adverse et de ce qu'ils arrivaient à
proposer dans le contenu du jeu on a
fait rentrer un attaquant avec un profil
un petit peu différent qui pesait un
petit peu plus sur la défense au but
je pense que ça nous a fait du bien ça
nous a permis de positionner le bloc
équipe un petit peu plus haut sur le
terrain jusqu'à la fin du match Garen
Colomb presse sans trouver la faille
dans la solide défense des Yvelines
trappe s'impose et poursuit sa dynamique
positive les automatismes commandent à
prendre une vraie une cohésion de groupe
est né donc tout se passe mieux au sein
du groupe maintenant il va falloir
travailler pour entretenir la dynamique
positive et aller chercher tous les
points qu'on peut qu'on peut aller
chercher par rapport au début de saison
déjà on est beaucoup mieux et on est sur
une bonne dynamique la dernière défaite
remonte au 10 décembre 2022 face à
Houilles trap pointe à la sixième place
au classement prochaine rencontre
dimanche 12 février avec la réception de
Conflans
on continue de parler de football au
monde de quelques échelons Nicolas en
National Versailles face à
Bourg-en-Bresse une défaite sur le score
de trois buts avec une incidence au
classement les versaillers se font
doubler par Martigues et le Red Star et
le pointe à la troisième place à trois
longueurs de Concarneau et Dunkerque à
la quatrième et cinquième position et on
revient justement sur cette défaite avec
notre invité par visioconférence c'est
Thibault Jacques joueur du Football Club
de Versailles vont sortir
alors on ne vous entend pas est-ce que
on peut mettre le son en plateau alors
on parlait à un lien instant Nicolas
venait de le dire de cette défaite trois
butins contre Bourg Péronnas qui vous
fait perdre du coup c'est la principale
conséquence au classement à cette
première place du championnat de
National et ça en plus face à votre
ancien club est-ce que la défaite a été
digéré il y a de de voilà depuis depuis
cette déconvenue vendredi
vendredi donc le plus important c'est de
c'est de vite switcher et préparer
absolument vendredi pour prendre des
points effectivement le championnat se
poursuit un dès vendredi avec la
réception d'Orléans on va en parler dans
un instant alors vous avez été vous avez
été mené assez rapidement dans ce match
et même assez lourdement de 0 au bout de
24 minutes de jeu qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné face à Bourg Peronnas
en fait je pense qu'ils ont on a un
petit peu payé cash les deux grosses
occasions qu'ils ont mis de suite et ils
mettent deux beaux buts et voilà après
on court après le score on revient juste
avant la mi-temps et malheureusement ce
penalty
nous nous plombe un petit peu en
deuxième mi-temps ou sinon on était
beaucoup beaucoup mieux et on était
vraiment à porter de d'égaliser ce qu'on
appelle l'effet du match vous étiez mené
deux buts à zéro il y a eu la réduction
du score juste avant le retour investir
de jeremen Lens qui a marqué d'ailleurs
un très très beau coup franc on a pu le
voir dans les images et effectivement le
trois business de Bourg Peronnas en
deuxième période pour peronna qui a
d'ailleurs fini la rencontre à 10
puisqu'il y a eu une exclusion en fin de
match j'ai eu alors peut-être un fait de
match vous allez nous dire si pour vous
c'est un fait de match si c'est
anecdotique 22e minute de jeu avec Kevin
finba qui a été stoppé de manière
irrégulière par un défenseur Bressant on
est juste avant le début à zéro
peut-être un penalty pour Versailles ou
pas en tout cas l'arbitre a estimé qu'il
n'y avait pas penalty vous estimez que
c'est un fait de match qui a pu changer
peut-être un tournant du match qui a pu
changer la suite de la rencontre ou ça a
été anecdotique selon vous
c'est sûr que si on avait obtenu un
penalty à ce moment-là tu aurais été
bien et je pense que revenir à un à ce
moment-là du match ça aurait été
important maintenant voilà faut pas se
cacher derrière ça c'est nous on pense
qu'il y avait penalty notre joueur aussi
nous dit qu'il y a penalty maintenant
voilà c'est une décision arbitrale donc
aussi plié et puis comme ça Nicolas avec
le match nul face au puits lors de la
18e journée cette défaite lors de la 19e
journée est-ce que il y a une dynamique
qui est cassée ou finalement c'est ça
reste un anecdotique ces deux matchs
la dynamique forcément avec la défaite
elle a été cassée maintenant il faut
vite repartir si on perd un match tous
les 7 ou 8 matchs je pense qu'on sera
pas mal à la fin donc là on a perdu ce
qu'il faut c'est enchaîner dès vendredi
aller chercher une victoire aller
prendre des points pour relancer la
dynamique et repartir sur une série de
matchs d'ailleurs petite réaction sur ce
but je le disais de gérer medlen c'est
un superbe coup franc ils sont troisième
but de la saison on commence à sentir
vraiment l'impact en tout cas de
l'extérieur vous allez me dire si de
l'intérieur il y a un vrai impact mais
on commence à ressentir l'extérieur son
impact sur le sur le l'effectif
Versailles on rappelle que si un jour
quand même qu'il y a une grosse
expérience derrière lui internationale
néerlandais qui est aussi des matchs qui
comptent des matchs de Coupe du monde à
son actif et ça y est voilà il apporte
vraiment quelque chose en plus dans cet
effectif
voilà que ça fait quoi d'avoir
jérémylens comme comme coéquipier
c'est forcément un atout alors voilà
peut-être que de l'extérieur on pense
que c'est que maintenant qu'il apporte
quelque chose forcément il enchaîne les
matchs donc ils sont de mieux en mieux
mais voilà depuis le début il apporte
son expérience il apporte son calme
c'était vraiment un super joueur mais
aussi une bonne personne donc pour le
groupe c'est positif donc on va voir sur
la suite de la saison le reste de son
apport alors Nicolas le disait ça vous
avez perdu du coup avec cette défaite la
première place de national mais tout est
serré il faut le il faut le dire
d'ailleurs en haut comme en bas du
classement on rappelle aussi qu'il y a
beaucoup de descentes à la fin de cette
saison nationale puisqu'à partir de la
13e place on descend en National 2 vous
êtes seulement à deux points de Marty
qui est l'actuel leader vous vous dites
quoi est-ce que c'est un coup au moral
ce que vous avez dit une dynamique
cassée ou finalement d'être aussi haut
pour un promu parce qu'on rappelle que
Versailles a été promu à l'issue de la
saison dernière bah c'est déjà une très
bonne chose à cette à ce stade de la
saison
alors à ce stade de la saison promis ou
pas c'est une bonne chose d'être là où
on est
première place ça c'est sûr mais le plus
important c'est d'être le plus haut
possible à la fin du championnat
aujourd'hui on a perdu deux places mais
voilà on est bien dans le coup on a des
matières importants qui arrivent à
commencer par vendredi contre Orléans
donc voilà pour l'instant tout
tourne correctement mais il faut pas se
relâcher parce que comme vous avez dit
c'est serré et il faut surtout pas
prendre de retard on a vu le classement
s'affiche et Nicolas alors justement si
on voit le classement s'afficher on voit
que derrière vous il y a Dunkerque et
Concarneau j'ai regardé un peu le le
calendrier vous recevez vous allez à
Dunkerque pardon le 17 février vous
recevez Concarneau le 27 février donc là
on note déjà deux matchs décisifs
peut-être pour la fin de la saison et
surtout ce qui se passe aussi dans le
calendrier de Versailles c'est que
Versailles recevra le Red Star le
weekend du 28 au 30 avril et votre
dernier match de la saison qui est le 22
entre le 22 et le 28 mai ce sera à
Martigues finalement le suspense va
durer jusqu'au bout de la saison pour
vous
c'est sûr peut-être que ça sera une
finale au dernier match ou pas ça dépend
de notre classement ou de leur
classement eux mais c'est voilà c'est un
championnat compliqué quand je vous ai
dit il y a un gros mois de février vous
l'avez souligné aussi avec des gros
adversaires donc il faut réussir à être
placé jusqu'à fin mars début avril et
puis après c'est sûr que les points
faudra les chercher partout pour obtenir
une des deux premières places vous avez
connu un Thibault Jacques une montée en
Ligue 2 c'était avec Chambly lors de la
saison je crois 2018-2019
c'est c'est un objectif avouer
aujourd'hui cette cette montée
potentiellement montée déjà en Ligue 2
pour Versailles qui est déjà promu dans
ce championnat de National
c'est pas que c'est un objectif avoué
c'est juste que un moment donné martyle
c'est pareil ils peuvent pas dire
aujourd'hui qui joue le maintien quand
on est en haut du classement on y prend
goût et tout le monde se prend en jeu
après voilà c'est il y a encore beaucoup
de matchs vraiment ça sera fin mars
début avril que là on pourra dire bon
ben on est dans les clous ben là
maintenant on joue clairement la montée
aujourd'hui il y a des grosses échéances
qui arrivent ça va être dur mais voilà
si on arrive à rester en haut le plus
longtemps possible après clairement on
sera là
on note quand même que Thibault n'a pas
prononcé la fameuse expression on prend
les matchs les uns après les autres il y
a quand même un objectif qui est annoncé
pour en regardant la perspective d'ici
fin avril une question justement vous
qui avez connu la Ligue 2 est-ce que
vous pensez que aujourd'hui Versailles a
suffisamment de maturité pour aller
jouer en Ligue 2
oui je pense déjà parce que beaucoup de
gens ont connu ce niveau là après voilà
il faut
la Ligue 2 c'est comme le National
forcément plus dur mais voilà il faut
sans cesse se remettre en question donc
la vérité d'hier sera pas spécialement
celle de demain donc aujourd'hui oui il
y a une bonne équipe des bons joueurs
qui je pense
obtiendrait un maintien en Ligue 2
maintenant l'objectif pour l'instant la
Ligue 2 c'est loin on y est pas encore
donc il faut d'abord travailler dans le
championnat national une toute dernière
question Thibault Jacques on le sait
aussi beaucoup de changements au sein du
club il y a eu l'arrivée d'un nouveau
coach depuis quelques mois Chris qui a
remplacé Youssef chibi c'était en
novembre le départ aussi de directeur
général Jean-Luc Arribart est-ce que ça
pèse dans les têtes ou ça vous arrivez à
en faire totalement abstraction de
forcément de ces changements coulisses
mais qui influe directement comme c'est
l'entraîneur qui influe directement sur
l'équipe première aussi
forcément on est impacté parce que comme
vous l'avez dit l'entraîneur voilà c'est
lui qui dirige l'équipe donc forcément
ça a été des décisions et des choix qui
ont impacté l'équipe maintenant voilà je
pense que le groupe a réussi à faire
abstraction à réussir à avancer et je
pense que ça le voit qu'avec le
classement qu'on a aujourd'hui on a
réussi à mettre de côté tout ça merci
Thibault et on vous souhaite bonne
chance pour la suite de la saison vous
l'avez dit Versailles qui sera sur les
terrains même sur le terrain de Jean
Bouin ce sera ce weekend ce sera même
vendredi une réception d'Orléans merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci bonne soirée
on pense lui Nicolas avec un autre
résultat alors là on est plus en
national mais on passe en National 2
cette fois-ci ont tenu en échec les
joueurs de Granville sur leur terrain
match nul un partout Poissy ce classe à
la troisième place derrière le leader
Rouen et le dauphin le Racing Club de
France le prochain match et ben il sera
en Normandie chez les leaders Roanne une
dernière information qui concerne alors
non juste avant je me perds un petit peu
dans les fiches on passe à un
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer ce weekend
d'abord pour les passionnés de de sport
US de foot américain oui alors juste
avant le Super Bowl qui opposera les
chips au Eagle ça sera dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi à Grégory j'espère que
vous serez devant votre télé bien sûr il
y a le choix la mi-temps il faut pas
manquer voilà exactement alors avant
d'aller aux États-Unis et bien il se
passera quelque chose à Élancourt ce
dimanche à 14h les Templiers se
déplacent sur le terrain des Diables
Rouges de Villepinte pour leur troisième
match de la saison dans le championnat
de 2e division casque d'or les élans
courtois doivent absolument s'imposer
après deux défaites au compteur ils ont
notamment perdu le dernier match sur
tapis vert suite à une irrégularité de
l'équipe médicale et s'ils veulent
monter en fin de saison ils n'ont pas le
choix il faudra gagner une personne une
dernière information cette fois-ci qui
concerne les Jeux olympiques de 2024
effectivement Grégory une course de
préparation à l'épreuve de VTT des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 sera programmée
les 23 et 24 septembre prochain sur la
colline dès l'encours dans le jargon on
appelle cela un Test Event il y aura
notamment des sportifs internationaux le
site point culminant d'Île-de-France
avec 231 mètres est actuellement en
pleine transformation pour pouvoir
accueillir 15000 spectateurs lors des JO
une fois terminé la piste olympique sera
un tracé de 4 km il sera emprunté par 72
athlètes en 2024 alors toute dernière
chose qu'on n'a pas vu tout à l'heure
l'animation s'afficher on parlait d'un
événement Bike & Run qui se déroule à 50
ans Yvelines ce week-end c'est
exactement deuxième édition de la Bike
and Run à Guyancourt organisé par le
triathlon club Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
c'est aux étangs de la minière une
course de 15 km pour les adultes à
partir de 16 ans et bien c'est le
rendez-vous est à 10h ce dimanche 12
février au Centre sportif les trois
mousquetaires info et inscription sur le
site
www.triathlon-kai.fr et on propose sur
tv70 ce sera cette semaine à un
reportage en immersion avec les
féminines rugby woman de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est une
séquence sportive qu'on va vous partager
un petit extrait avant le reportage qui
sera disponible cette semaine sur notre
antenne exactement Grégory leur surnom
ce sont les montaigneuses et je peux
vous dire qu'elles sont vraiment
teigneuses les joueuses de rugby de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors la semaine
dernière on les avait vu dans les
vestiaires en pleine préparation à la
fois psychologique et aussi mental la
capitaine haroung les joueuses avant de
rentrer sur la pelouse pour
l'échauffement et justement
l'échauffement bah c'est maintenant
ça va être chaud
2 3 4 5 6 7
mettez-moi les trois quarts sur les
quatre plots ici les avances sur les
trois plus vite
les boucliers
les sprint
allez go
ûter
OK
c'est compensé qui mettrait au moins une
équipe pour nous respecter il nous
respecte pas ils font démarrer leur
équipe on va la rouler dessus il vous
prenne pour des petits ils vont vous
prendre de haut on va leur rouler dessus
faut qu'on leur montre qu'on est chez
nous faut qu'on leur montre tout de
suite qu'on a les crocs la fille elle
est trop bas vous la ratez c'est pas
grave on va tout le monde va rater des
plaquages aujourd'hui ce qui est
important c'est celui d'après si chacune
vous gagnez vous rencontrez ça va le
faire je veux que mes remplaçantes
aujourd'hui elles soient meilleurs que
les titulaire c'est bon pour tout le
monde allez serrer serrer serrer
tu rentres à la 20e ok une fois prête à
l'aventure et tu prends dorcer avec toi
pour l'échappement
voilà pour cette extrait de reportage
reportage complet à retrouver cette
semaine sur l'antenne de TV 78 merci
beaucoup Nicolas pour toutes ces
informations sportives vous restez avec
moi peut-être encore quelques minutes
pour parler dans un instant des sujets
d'actualité
et il y en a un ce soir à la une de
l'actualité c'est bien sûr cette
nouvelle journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites c'est lynchal
qui est venu en plateau pour nous parler
des perturbations à prévoir à quoi
faut-il s'attendre pour la journée de
demain mais en effet les deux premiers
mouvements avaient été très bien suivi
et bien qu'elle semble plus modérée des
perturbations sont à prévoir dans les
transports et services publics pour
demain alors dans les transports
justement la SNCF invite les voyageurs à
annuler ou reporter leur déplacement ce
sera également compliqué en
Île-de-France comptez un train sur trois
pour les lignes NL et j et d'autres un
sur trois pour la ligne u le RER A et B
sont également perturbés n'hésitez pas
bien sûr à vous rendre sur les sites de
la RATP ou transilien.com pour connaître
le trafic en temps réel les syndicats de
l'éducation seront également mobilisés
ce mardi le 31 janvier dernier en
observait un taux d'enseignant grévistes
de 25,9% selon l'éducation nationale les
syndicats en recensés 50% un nouvel
appel à la grève massive et à la
manifestation a été lancée par l'Inter
en tout cas les syndicats lycéens et
étudiants pensaient à vous renseigner
auprès de votre mairie pour des
informations plus précises concernant
notamment les établissements scolaires
dans les raffineries la CGT a également
appelée à débrailler sur 48 heures mais
pendant ces deux jours il n'y aura pas
d'arrêt de production seulement une
baisse de débit cela ne devrait donc pas
avoir d'impact à la pompe pour cette
journée de mobilisation plus de 15 car
vont partir de plusieurs villes des
départements pour rejoindre la place de
l'Opéra à Paris on retrouve par exemple
Mantes-la-Jolie Poissy trappes Élancourt
ou encore Versailles une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation et d'ores et
déjà prévu le 11 février prochain mais
pour l'heure la SNCF n'a pas eu pas à la
grève merci Céline pour toutes ces
précisions et on parle justement de ce
sujet avec notre invité par
visioconférence Natalia pouziref qui est
normalement connecté où nous entendez
bien
très bien merci on vous entend également
bonsoir vous êtes donc la députée
renaissance de la sixième
circonscription des Yvelines on parle
avec vous dans un instant de cette
conférence des bagues vous organisez à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye sur la thématique
de la fin de vie mais forcément le sujet
du jour c'est aussi cette réforme des
retraites retraite le texte est examiné
depuis aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle par
les députés alors on avait eu une forte
mobilisation le 31 janvier il y a un
sondage aussi faible qui est sorti hier
qui fait état que 69% des Français
seraient contre la réforme et le texte
entre aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
nationale on le sait avec ses 20 000
amendements déposés par par l'opposition
d'émotions également de de rejet quel
était l'ambiance cet après-midi là
quelle est l'ambiance au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale
bien écoutez nous sommes en train de
lancer le débat mais le démarrage a été
difficile a été très chahuté je dois
dire puisqu'il y avait des contestations
des argusies juridiques mais finalement
nous allons procéder
et j'espère que les esprits seront un
peu plus apaisés par
la suite c'est une semaine décisive pour
la majorité avec la
l'examen en première lecture de ce texte
vous l'abordez comment cette semaine
comme je disais la majorité est solide
nous avons fait notre propre travail
d'amendement nous espérons seulement que
le débat aura lieu parce que en l'état
actuel des choses il y a 18000
amendements déposés par la nups et que
c'est de fonction caractérisée ça veut
dire que nous avons jusqu'au 17 février
nous ne sommes pas forcément
à même de d'examiner tout le texte
et ça c'est un regret parce que nous
nous avons construit quelques
amendements toujours lequel nous
aimerions qui est un vrai débat et le
débat de puisse se dérouler dans le
meilleur état d'esprit dans le calme
possible mais ce n'est pas visiblement
ce que vous l'avez
devoir retourner bientôt dans
l'hémicycle donc on va aborder le
deuxième sujet ce pour lequel vous êtes
celui pour lequel vous êtes venus nous
parler c'est donc ce cette conférence
débat qui est organisée ce jeudi à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la fin de vie
parlons-en ensemble c'est à la salle
Jacques tatie le début de la conférence
est fixée à 19h30 on va peut-être
pouvoir avoir une animation s'afficher
pour avoir toutes les informations et ce
sera en présence de la ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé Agnès Firmin le
Bodo de députés également et aussi de
représentants du monde médical et
associatif on précise juste qu'il y a en
ce moment toute une réflexion autour de
la fin de vie à une compréhension une
convention citoyenne qui réunit 150
français et qui planchent sur le sujet
et qui doit rendre ses conclusions en
mars c'est le président de la République
a parlé aussi d'une nouvelle législation
qui pourrait voir le jour d'ici la fin
2023 pourquoi organiser cette conférence
des bas Natalia pusirev c'est pour
nourrir le débat justement au niveau
départemental au niveau régional
absolument pour nourrir le débat et
j'espère que nous pourrons d'ailleurs
faire un compte rendu et le remonter à
la ministre directement qui sera là mais
c'est aussi parce que j'ai été
interpellé très régulièrement sur le
sujet c'est une question qui intéresse
les habitants de la circonscription je
pense que effectivement nous sommes tous
confrontés
au sujet de la fin de vie d'un proche ou
à se poser des questions en ce qui nous
concerne et donc ce débat doit répondre
à une attente il doit être je pense
permettre de voir tous les aspects de la
question moi j'ai tenu à ce qui est un
philosophe qui soit là plus éclairé
c'est des questions d'éthique il y aura
aussi l'ancien député classe qui
représente le commissaire Conseil
national d'éthique qui était porteur de
la loi classe
Leonetti qui fait
référence aujourd'hui on verra donc avec
ces représentants ainsi que des
représentants de l'association ADMD qui
prône le droit de mourir dans la dignité
ainsi qu'avec la le corps médical qui
sera présent également on verra s'il y a
d'autres équilibres à trouver des
évolutions envisagées à cette voix en
tout cas nous sommes nous sommes pour
accueillir tous les publics qui
s'intéressent à cette question qui je
dis bien et forcément universel
évolution ou pas de cette loi statue
cours on le précise dans la loi classe
Leonetti interdit l'euthanasier le
suicide assisté aujourd'hui c'est la loi
qui est en vigueur vous le disiez on
peut aller vers une évolution mais mais
tout est ouvert parce que Emmanuel
Macron disait avant l'élection
présidentielle vouloir aller au-delà
peut-être sur le modèle belge et
dépénalisé le tanasie finalement avant
de dire qu'il y avait pas forcément un
modèle qui prédominait tout est ouvert
aujourd'hui encore absolument tout est
ouvert parce que je crois qu'il faut
avoir la parole des experts aussi c'est
pour ça que à lors de ce débat il y aura
aussi une psychologue et une infirmière
des soins palliatifs donc les personnes
qui vont justement qui approchent le
plus près le patient en fin de vie et il
y a aussi des questions légitimes que se
pose la population sur ses droits sa
liberté de pouvoir décider de sa fin de
vie donc je crois que ça reste très
ouvert et il y a des cas particuliers
comme par exemple la maladie Sherco faut
savoir comment on peut traiter ces cas
très graves qui qui plongent les malades
dans une grande douleur et sans pouvoir
agir sur leur propre destin et enfin je
pense qu'une question déjà évidentes
c'est d'avoir des palliatifs qu'ils
soient
dotés et répartis également sur le
territoire car en tout cas il ne peut
pas y avoir d'inégalités
soins palliatifs ce n'est plus possible
aujourd'hui dans la France si on veut
pouvoir accompagner dignement vous les
personnes en fin de vie et vous l'avez
dit aussi l'objectif c'est de faire
remonter les conclusions tout ce qui va
être dit au cours de cette soirée l'idée
c'est de pouvoir les faire remonter
absolument moi je pense que nous aurons
un compte-rendu qui sera disponible en
sortie de débat avec quelques remarques
pertinentes on ne va pas tout réinventer
mais j'espère que les échanges croisés
d'enrichir le débat et comme la ministre
sera présente elle aura donc ces
éléments de réflexion
merci Nathalie on va vous laisser
retourner dans l'hémicycle on lisait
avec une semaine chargée pour pour la
majorité et le début de l'examen dans
l'hémicycle l'ensemble est nationale par
les députés de ce projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites merci d'avoir été
avec nous
merci à vous donc c'est jeudi 9 février
19h30 salle Jacques Tati
Saint-Germain-en-Laye merci voilà on le
rappelle on va voir peut-être une
nouvelle fois l'animation s'afficher
pour toutes les informations avec donc
cette conférence débat sur la fin de vie
ce sera jeudi à 19h30 à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye salle et Jacques
Tati pour retrouver le lien
d'inscription on se rend directement sur
les comptes Facebook et Twitter de
Natalia pousireff je le rappelle député
de la sixième circonscription des
Yvelines qui était avec nous on va
parler à présent d'Europe si je vous dis
Europe en plateau est-ce que ça vous
évoque quelque chose Nicolas l'Union
européenne l'Union européenne
est passé par la tête aussi vous savez
qu'il y avait une Maison de l'Europe
dans les Yvelines où il forcément on en
parle à la maison qui a peut-être donné
naissance à l'Union européenne la maison
Jean Monnet
ou ont été rédigés les prémices du
traité de Rome forcément fondateur de
cette union européenne on parlait pas
d'Union Européenne encore à l'époque
mais en tout cas ça ça a jeté les 1957
le traité c'est ça on confirmera
peut-être en régie on va parler d'Europe
justement à présent c'est pour ça que
vous ai lancé sur la question avec la
nouvelle étape pour Gira sur les
initiatives vertes en milieu rural ce
projet
Erasmus plus de la Maison de l'Europe
des Yvelines auquel sont associés
également des pays étrangers la Grèce
l'Allemagne la Pologne la Suède aussi
les Pays-Bas c'est d'ailleurs au
Pays-Bas que les délégations sont
retrouvés pour découvrir ce qui ce qui
est fait en ce qui est fait en faveur de
l'environnement et des idées dont
pourrait dont on pourrait s'inspirer on
regarde tout de suite le reportage de
Corentin Alonso de nos confrères de
radio sensation
vendre ses produits directement au
consommateur voilà le mode de
fonctionnement de cette coopérative
alimentaire située à sibranda Boren en
Frise dans ce potager en permaculture on
récolte une centaine de fruits et
légumes différents que l'on peut se
procurer avec un abonnement saisonnier
en free
Ia ça permet que
les connais les légumes ils savent d'où
vient et comme ça on fait un lien entre
les producteurs et les consommateurs
dans la région on recense plus de 200
initiatives semblables liées à
l'économie circulaire
depuis la guerre en Ukraine réduire sa
consommation de gaz et devenue un devoir
stratégique pour l'Union européenne à
egg village de 2000 habitants à côté
d'un grand lac on a décidé de miser sur
l'Aqua thermique
nous travaillons sur un gros projet
prendre la chaleur du lac en été
l'enterrer profondément dans le sol
la chaleur restera là
et en hiver on pourra grâce à des moyens
technologiques la déterrer pour chauffer
les maisons
on aurait plus besoin de gaz mais nous
pourrions chauffer les maisons grâce à
la chaleur de l'eau
dernière visite pour les délégations du
projet JIRA itswetta house un bâtiment
administratif d'une centrale électrique
construit avec 44% de matériaux recyclés
avec parfois des techniques inattendues
comme cette table réalisée à partir
d'anciens jeans et c'est donc une autre
façon de concevoir des building des
maisons des qui permettent de prendre en
charge et de prendre en considération
tous les problèmes liés à la
construction j'ai été impressionné par
une table qui est en fait une table de
comprimé de Jean ancien qui a été mais
avec une une sorte de colle biologique
et c'est assez impressionnant pour ça
les délégations du projet JIRA se
retrouveront en Allemagne du 23 au 26
février
et ce projet autour de l'environnement
en Europe sera l'objet d'un numéro
spécial de zone Europe de nos confrères
de radio sensation à retrouver justement
sur Radio sensation des samedis à 19h et
également sur TV 78.com avant de se
quitter on fait un nouveau point sur la
météo de demain
et le retour du froid dans les Yvelines
il faudra vous couvrir et peut-être
gratter votre pare-brise mais le soleil
sera de la partie il fera 0° le matin à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan et
même moins 1 degré à Rambouillet dans le
sud du département dans l'après-midi
toujours le soleil et le froid c'est
toujours un poil plus frais à
Rambouillet avec 4 degrés 5 degrés sur
le reste du territoire et ce mardi 7
février c'est la sainte Eugénie vous
connaissez des Eugénies Céline
à Eugénie qui est et bien la sœur de
Justine Brazier notre ancien ancienne
collègue de TV 78 voilà petit clin
d'oeil à Justine c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci à Nicolas merci Céline et on va se
quitter sur ces images regardez qui ont
été tournées par l'association du dragon
bleu à Triel-sur-Seine puisqu'on
célébrait le nouvel an chinois il se
poursuit encore quelques jours le nouvel
an chinois année du lapin d'eau et le
nouvel an chinois Triel-sur-Seine est
organisé depuis quelques années par
l'association du Dragon Bleu 4000
personnes ont participé à cet événement
et vous le voyez avec à chaque fois des
défilés traditionnels dragon de belles
images voilà pour célébrer le nouvel an
chinois
merci d'avoir été avec nous et une très
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]